is the fact correct that he received $756 that
is correct that's where he worked 83 hours in
addition making a total of 123 hours and for those
83 hours he received double-time not double-double
time at the rate of seven dollars per hour that
doesn't check out here we have here that it worked
40 hours it's straight time it worked 43 hours
at double-time and 20 hours on double-double
timer golden honey is that right or wrong it's
an it's an error I'm sure standard breaker
[Music]
certainly does not this is a very unusual
situation and one that developed just prior
to test we originally set a schedule for
the fall operations of October 1st to the
first shot we started construction in
June of 1951 we started which is very
unusual for us anywhere in the program
on a fifty four hour work week because
the time was short and we had to have the
control folks ready for the 51 file shop
I am here at my own request to deny
unqualifiedly various statements about
me which were made before this committee by
one Whittaker Chambers day before yesterday
I appreciate the committee's having thumped me
granted my request I welcome the opportunity to
answer to the best of my ability any inquiries
the members of this committee may wish to ask
me I am NOT and never have been a member of
the Communist Party I do not and never have
adhered to the tenets of the Communist Party
the statements about me made by mr. chambers
are complete fabrications I think my record in
the government service speaks for itself to any
organizations at the attorney general's office as
well because I have not mr. chairman my co stated
as your wife would have blown that he goes
that he has not the best of Minot and I think
I wouldn't she never been a communist not
again I must say better than mr. change if
you were you charged with an executive agency
would you employ a communist as a chairman
question yeah I might have been that too late
the witness that he didn't he didn't refuse to
answer any questions on the ground that it might
incriminate him and it didn't bring the lawyer
you had to tell him that says the charges made
by miss Bentley are false and fantastic I can
only conclude that she is a neurotic liar I am
NOT and I've been a loyal I am and have been a
loyal American citizen and was a faithful
government employee still matter [Music]
on the grounds if any answer and they give me that
is correct sir I refuse to answer this question on
the grounds that any answer only give to this
question babe yourself incriminated I refuse
to answer this question on the same grounds that
any answer only gave to this question in Trinity
there you know Alger Hiss I refuse to answer this
question on the grounds that any other enemy give
this question made yourself incriminating the
you know find the co-ceo we I refuse to answer
this question on the grounds that any answer and
they give this question maybe self incriminating
I would like to inform the members of
this committee that I have been taking
testimony and executive sessions for
several months in the past and I have
it has been testified to me on the highest
authority by the highest authority that
two shipments of uranium oxide one of the
fundamentals of the atomic bomb were made
to Russia from a obscure airfield in
the western part of the nation in 1943